all right so cody tell me about your
relationship with mary um
there's just nothing to talk about
really wow that's that's hard to hear
like friends i mean
listen there was a hardness in our
marriage that was so difficult and so
antagonistic i didn't know why we were
in it it took a long time a lot of
counseling as we go through all of this
for me to finally go marry i don't i
just don't see us getting back together
and why aren't we getting back together
because we will go back to the way we
were before there's just no chance that
i ever want that again
but why not leave her at that point it's
a double standard
they can leave whenever they want
i can't it is not a double standard
because you emotionally have left and
abandoned them in some ways right well
police
well i take the word back because i take
offense to that word of abandonment when
mary had an affair
she was leaving my ass because she was
like i'm done with this i am done with
you i have done she made it clear to
everybody that she was getting out of
there
she was done with us and she can't admit
it now because we rallied we circled the
wagons as a family to protect her when
she realized that she'd been duped
she was deceived she was leaving she
found something better she was leaving
me for a better richer man
and because we did that
in her own mind she doesn't even realize
what happened she sees herself as a
victim
which is true but that she had done
nothing wrong
and she would have never even been the
victim if she wouldn't have done
something wrong
did you and cody ever have an honest
conversation about the catfishing
i thought that we did and i thought that
that he
knew where i was coming from
you know like how that all happened and
what happened well he thought you were
leaving him for another person right he
did
yeah so he felt betrayed right there
absolutely and i get that i wasn't
leaving but during that time
because i was very much in a dark place
i considered all my options
just because i was trying to figure out
what i needed to do but i feel like cody
took it like that oh he definitely did
did i start talking to this person
absolutely i did did i think that i was
talking to a friend absolutely
it literally was not just uh
um okay well i'm gonna meet some dude
online and uh fall in love and want to
leave my family a lot of people like to
look at that as the defining moment in
the fracture in in mine and cody's
relationship
and it wasn't
did he
say i have an issue of trust with you
now as a result of it oh yeah
yeah
[Music]
you